mari finalmente sei online
quel caffè che mi avevi promesso oppure stasera che fai
aperitivo faccetta ammiccante bicchierino
di vino dai che ci tengo mari rispondi
yuhuuu faccina perplessa mari dai ma ci sei?
tre puntini
mari mari yuhuu
ei ragazzi guardate questo meme
bellissimo che bello mi ricorda
tantissimo un altro meme aspetta che te lo
mando no vabe top i gattini che si fanno i massaggi faccina che ride faccina che ride
silenzioso per una settimana
allora stasera ragazze cenetta vi porto
in un posto che conosco faccio beato fra
le donne la bionda e la mora le veline
no va beh ma quanto é sfigato secondo me
ci sta provando di brutto con te ma va
ci sta provando con te ma a te piace? a me per niente e a te? zero allora scarichiamolo
edo ci dispiace ma questa sera non
possiamo io ho il compleanno di mio
padre e io di mia sorella
facciamo la prossima volta va bene?
faccina col sorriso buona serata manina
che saluta pollice in su pollice in su pollice in su
oi ragazzi venerdì sera cena
con gli ex compagni di classe?
no proprio non c'ho voglia quegli sfigati?
dai piuttosto noi quattro pochi ma buoni ma
dai ma Maryna poi non risponderà mai
ma figurati quando risponde quella mari ci sei? ma perché
lei è impegnata adesso col suo nuovo
lavoro secondo me non risponde secondo me se la mena
silenzioso per un anno
tareshjwb fkjenfajkewrfnerfvberjefewrf
tutto ok? carjskid wefcfkjwekfenkewfjefnaemwf cnakjfwnkawe
faccina perplessa
meno male che eri stanco mi hai mandato
la buona notte alle 21.18 sono le 23 34
cosa cavolo ci fai on line? sai non
riuscivo ad andare a dormire e allora
guardavo le nostre foto in chat
mi fa andare a letto col sorriso...
allora va bene niente buona notte amorino buonanotte ciambellina
con gli zuccherini bacino bacino bacino bacino
punto interrogativo scusa
ero in bagno ma allora quell'aperitivo
di domani di cui parlavamo?
ma tu non eri fidanzato io? ma se ci siamo lasciati almeno due mesi fa ah e se anticipassimo
a stasera? io ho casa libera e non
ho niente da fare sono lí tra mezz'ora
fuocherello fuocherello fuocherello
faccina ammiccante
mamma stasera esco con Erika non vengo a cena
sto scrivendo
sto scrivendo sto scrivendo
ok
semore molto rapida mamma eh
raga siete resuscitati da ieri sera?
io sono uno zombie madonna io berrò acqua per 3 mesi
comunque serata pazzesca che ridere the walking dead mamma mia ma la musica?
adesso ti faccio vedere foto foto
ti ho fatto un video mentre eri ubriaco ieri edo
guarda come eri sbronzo ti ricatterò a vita incommentabile mentre vomito nei bagni?
questo fanno gli amici abbandona il gruppo
ma veramente ma quant hai bevuto?
cioè moltiplicando tutto ma maryna?
nooooo no non l'ha fatto apposta é la peggiore veramente sempre stata un pó strana dai
secondo me c'avrà qualcosa con noi e voi dicevate che non se la menava?
non so ultimamente é un pó strana adesso le scrivo in privato perché non va bene ragazzi
se questo video arriverà a 60.000 like sto scrivendo
gireremo la seconda parte sto scrivendo
se non l'avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale sto scrivendo e attivate le
notifiche cliccando sulla campanella che
trovate vicino al tasto d'iscrizione
sto scrivendo e seguitemi su tutti gli
altri social facebook instagram e tiktok
sto scrivendo